many people on the left have taken on an
exclusively structural understanding of
racism in which if you're part of a
supposedly uh uh marginalized group it
is impossible for you to have prejudices
against to be racist against a member of
a supposedly dominant group because
we've thrown the older conception of
racism based on individual bias
completely out of the window there's a
superimposition in a sort of strangely
neocolonial way of American race
categories on everybody else so when
people analyze something like the Israel
Palestine conflict they try to fit Jews
into the box of white people and
Palestinians into the box of people of
color and so even though at this point a
plurality of Israelis are Mahi Jews who
have thrown out of Middle Eastern
countries in violent ways over the
course of the last 75 years and have a
very similar skin tone to Palestinians
they are perceived as whites who are
part of this dominant group